So there's a lot of different types of autoimmune disorders depending on what cell structure,
what tissue.
An autoimmune disease is named after the primary tissue of destruction.
That is why a person, they have started out with thyroid issues, and then they ended up
with arthritis issues, and then they ended up with MS.
Oh, I got three autoimmune disease, no, you're only got one.
It's just destroyed three different tissues, and it's just continuing to progress.
So you have to find out what the antigen is, and you have to figure out how you're going
to get rid of that antigen, and that's another five-hour lecture itself.
But you've got to find somebody that will help that.
And you talk about biotoxins that your immune system is unable to kill.
Hello?
Anybody spell RIFE for me?
You know, that is a huge player.
If you're going to be able to kill a biotoxin that goes into the cell, it goes inside the
cell and hides inside the cell, how are you going to do it?
We're going to use bigger antibiotics, are we going to use stronger nutraceuticals?
Well, it's hard to use nutraceuticals to kill a biotoxin if the person's TH1 dominant,
because what do you have to use to kill biotoxin if the person's TH1 dominant?
You don't have a whole lot of tools in your tool bag there.
You can't give TH1 stimulants.
RIFE doesn't stimulate a TH1 response directly.
So a huge player at killing a biotoxin.
Does that make sense?